islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can
brothers and sisters and dear friends
alexa let there be light
okay
oh
welcome guys assalamu alaikum alexa of
course how are you guys doing
don't worry there's no free mixing going
on because you know it's a female a meal
here don't worry sir it's a robot it's
not real
who's this person
this person's called cezanne axel she's
a turkish singer sold over 40 million um
albums around the world
very popular very liked by many people
now she recently made a track um and in
that track she insults adam alaysalam
and howa yeah maybe peace
the peaceful spinal talib on both of
them
the question that needs to be asking why
does a singer drop to level to such a
level stoop to such a level of insulting
the prophets of allah
well brothers and sisters when you don't
have iman when you have belief
when you have something that you stand
up for you fall for anything like
malcolm x said
and to us as muslims it really angers us
it really saddens us to see that people
their animosity and hatred towards islam
is so grave so great that they would
drop to any levels to the points they
would even contradict their self if i
was to go
and i'm sure someone who's really dear
to her is mustafa kemal ataturk yes one
of the i wouldn't say the founders of
turkey but somebody who defended turkey
against you know uh occupation etc so
you know
if i was to go and insult mustafa kemal
trust me i will not survive and i'll be
lynched and most likely be killed maybe
you know beheaded you know thrown into
the sea or something like that
where these people does beloved to them
don't you dare insult them
when it's the prophets of god it's
freedom of speech and this is exactly
what's happening by a few individuals
out there who want to gain some
political votes
to
defending her saying that it is
just freedom of speech
let's watch what she said what she had
to say
so as you guys saw from there subhan
allah it's absolutely unbelievable
she look i mean well i'm sorry look at
her face one like this look look at her
face
this is the level allah says if you
forget my remembrance i will make you
forget your own self
look at your face one lie look at her
face
botox surgery surgery until they look
like a creature
there's another creature called apus
which you can see on the screen look at
the guy's face
look at the guy's face okay this one was
a botox she's like that yeah this other
guy allah has done this face yeah we
believe allah's creation i'm not saying
that this person is this or that future
i'm saying allah has done his face we
can see some people's face are you know
blackened
yeah the hypocrisy
if like i said before if that was me
insulting churchill insulting the flag
in france or anywhere else you're
finished you are not allowed that's
about inshallah and i'll be debating
this little fool on my left in may
inshallah and humiliate him like a
little scum he is an intellectual fraud
an ignoramus and this freedom of speech
advocate when i asked him about what's
his opinions on mustafa kemal
yeah he diverted the topic because he
knows very well what will happen to him
he knows very well what would happen to
him and that is exactly our points
my point brothers and sisters
i was here at a friend's house
marshall's got beautiful place i'm gonna
go now alexa
good night
okay